this morning on the dish matunic oysters
and the man who went from farming
shellfish by himself to delivering ted
talks and establishing one of the best
oyster bars in the world perry rosso has
become an evangelist for what we're
calling aquaculture which may be needed
now more than ever he believes this
provides the perfect combination of
clean water and great food both of which
are jeff glor experienced on a recent
trip to rhode island
laguardia you ready
he's ready laguai has to approve all
oyster that's right he's the head of
operations over here
on a sun-soaked new england day
perry rosso took us to potter pond just
off but sheltered from the heaviest
waves of the atlantic
the ideal spot to harvest a food that is
changing everything here oysters
right off the back of the boat
it's an extra gives you an extra flavor
probably not the cleanest thing in the
world right
not bad
add that to the list
rosso started fishing as a boy and
digging little neck clams when he was
12.
he graduated from the university of
rhode island after studying aquaculture
then started a small oyster farm in 2002
so we got a leading space to grow nice
you got little shrimps jumping around in
there today rosso operates seven acres
of water farming with more than 16
million oysters
plus bay scallops
really interesting animals they have
eyes they have 32 sets of eyes on the
top and 32 sets on the bottom and you
can see them they're like little blue
specks
russo has also built a huge nearby
vegetable farm so we have beets salad
greens couple varieties of kale over
here we got our peppers and our tomatoes
started
and
salad greens over here as well as the
asparagus
all of which supply his restaurants
which has become a smash hit for diners
across the east coast
matunic oyster bar
you're not a chef no
you've never been a foodie
i've become a foodie how was the raw bar
feast over here
by now though rosso has taken his
broader message global
delivering ted talks about the
importance and sustainability of
aquaculture to feed a crowded and
hungrier planets shellfish farming is
the epitome of sustainable agriculture
aquaculture sounds like agriculture
aquaculture is agriculture we're sitting
here you can sit here and look at and
look at where your food comes from
line of sight right it's important i
mean we have uh you know the vegetable
farm and the oyster farms all within a
mile of here
to be able to see
you know where your food is coming from
see the farmers coming in with the
oysters
putting them right in the fridge and
serving them right here you know it's an
unique thing and i think you know oyster
farm geek thought is you know this
incoming tide is delivering food to my
babies out there you know
one of the great things about oyster
farming you don't have to feed the
oysters they eat the naturally occurring
phytoplankton in the water so this is
delivering food to the animals it's
lunch for them right now it's lunch for
them and it's cleaning the water so it's
uh beneficial
there are a lot of people who come in
who just don't won't eat oysters right
do you
make it your mission to try to convert
them well i i do try to get them into
oysters and our oysters the tunic
oysters are uh they're a petite oyster
so they're not big so they're a little
bit more palatable for someone who might
be a little wary of eating oysters it's
almost like it's like like a gateway
oyster the gateway oyster is what i like
to call it this right
rosso has built his menu slow and steady
the breath of which we were able to
sample
starting of course
with oysters so these are the tunics
right here those are the ones we farm
raise out in potter pond i'm digging in
yeah try one of those
great you think good
sweet
and the crisp the sweet it is crisp
to accompany rosso's best seller we also
had a matunic special passion fruit
oysters with salmon eggs and cucumbers
soaked in sake if you prefer your
oysters cooked there were the bourbon
oysters
also an asparagus and tomato salad with
vegetables from his farm and a local
seafood salad
calamari
oyster stew with a rosemary cream broth
and this quinoa crab dish that blew our
minds
look at this sucker so you've got quinoa
avocado
crab
drizzle over the top is we have
lemon zest aioli there
oh that's fantastic nice
so good
not to be overlooked the tuna with
creole mustard and mashed potatoes
and a ridiculous lobster pizza he
recently debuted it's a pizza we put on
the menu during covet i was researching
what's the most popular takeout food
pizza and so i said i wanted to make the
best seafood pizza in the world and i
think we might have come close to it we
got some projects some truffle some
arugula on there it's really delicious
it should be illegal this is crazy how
good it really is that pizza is
absurd for dessert there was a blueberry
crumble anima tunic signature key lime
pops
[Music]
the full scale of rosso's creation here
is amazing
even though he still feels like the
little kid scrapping for clams just to
make a few bucks you talk about this a
lot about your fear
of failure of not
succeeding do you still feel that way
yeah yeah absolutely
you're never satisfied uh i i don't
you know like to think of myself as
someone who's never satisfied but the
reality uh might be that yeah
and in the end
people get a healthier ocean because of
it and
and good food yeah there's definitely so
we should enjoy your pain
we we can enjoy it because jeff made
sure as did marcy waldman that we had
this and sent straight we've got the
loves the oysters the gateway oysters as
they were described
some of this key lime pop and a and a
beverage of course wonderful
cheers cheers cheers to to that and to
twinkling yeah
i just love watching jeff eat food and
enjoy it it is just like i feel like i
can taste it when he's up there talking
about the illegal lobster pizza and the
gateway drug yeah no wonderful beautiful
stuff